ええええええ
最初に断っておきますこの動画はとても
し物の悪い動画ですもう事前に行ってきましたからねあの
どっちかいうとものを吐く系ですねものを吐くノート加工なんかこうやってなるのが
苦手な方は見ないほうがいいですが見ないでくださいもうそういうのが追ってちょっと
いいよみたいなむしろもメカさんの面白い大会していたら1
楽しい動画になるぞもうちょっと通告したからねここからは皆さん自己責任でご覧
ください
こんにちははじめシャトーです皆様ゲロ吐いたことありますか
あの基本的に下郎履くときってこういろんなタイピングがあると思うんですよ体調が
悪い時とか食べ物食べれなくなったときとかお酒の飲み過ぎで気持ち悪くなった時
乗り物によってこう酔っちゃった時とこれも時代です
がまずかったに黒さてたりしてハイツの時といろんなことがあるんですけども今回私は
とある
とんでもない動画を手に入れましたどうぞそれでちょっと気持ち悪いんで全部モザイク
かかってるんですけどここの通り成人男性がある匂い嗅ぐと
ご覧くださいあっという間に白生えてしまうという
とんでもない元素が起きておりますこのとある男性の後輩はそんなわけないんだろう僕
が確かめてやりますよとだけの後輩もこうやってその謎の物体の近くによってしまうと
ニオイ嗅ぎます
ウイッグあった
眼帯ことでしょうその後輩も馬車に自然にゲロ吐いてしまうというのですよきたねえな
見たくねえ飯
すごいでしょ2人の男性が匂いを書くだけでゲロ吐いてしまっていますこれは見た
とある男性の先輩はこれすごいんじゃないかと思っており書いてみるよというわけで
もう一度鍵に行きました
もうすでに危ないんですけどもまさかそんなに帰り使うことはないだろうとレンジ度
その
とある物質の近くへ持ってに追いかけと青危ない
滝
ようですがまだ大丈夫ところがあっ
はい
すごい量でましたね3回連続でゲロ吐くです人が自由に書くだけでそれを切った強いが
これはおかしいたと思いまして
もう一度その常に陰に行きましたそれから4回連続はないぞということによってみます
よ
goo
動画よお外入ってしまっていますが
それぞれねずっとあっちじゃこれはというけどでもう一度上位二切ってみます
はいっ
う
はぁっとこれは渡りましたらいかがだったでしょうか
世の中でいろんな議論吐くトリガーというのがあると思うんですけどもう本題の
トリガーは二容易です
何の入荷と言いますけどそこにあるんですけど頭ん中で交通とスープみたいなのか豆乳
スープみたいの作ってくれたんですけどもうけど頑張って食べたんですけど量が多くて
ちょっとどこっ
あってそれをちょっと喉頭鏡とか言ったりして放置してて気づいたら3日間か4日
くらい経ってました
である日なんか部屋がすごい匂いするなと思って来部屋を探索してたらそのキッズに
なったさんの豆乳スープみたいですがか弁護士だ伝わらないでしょうそこの
youtube のみんな含めちょっと伝えられないんだけどもう人生でこれほど
すごいもんだねーぞってくらいと匂いでニオイ嗅いだ瞬間
今してしまうという一種の何か特殊な物質ダークまたに久しい物質に変化してしまって
いたのでふつうて捨てちゃったんですよすいで袋に vip って捨てちゃったんです
けども
もったいないと思ってしまいました動けない匂い嗅ぐだけで弾ける物質なんて妄想じゃ
ないと思うんで今ごみ袋に入ってるんですけども今度はそちらのに追いかけだけで絶対
色が出る物質を年度はサルベージしてウビンに集合したいと思いますいう中だってこ
動画で吐くシーンがよく使われることがあるかもしれないんですけどこれちょっと
じゃあ素晴らしいねりゅうちぇろは摂津が誕生するんじゃないか
僕を持っているのでよだれが出た今回ちょっと頑張ってゴミ袋の中から伝説の物質を
食べベージュしようと思います
で箱
では上げていきましょうドンキの巣クロスゴミ袋20日事じゃないでしょ
この中に匂いを嗅ぐと絶対議論があってつは物質が入っておりますでネイバーからこの
小瓶に移して私が確保しますヒールでも誰でもちょっと履かせるように出てくれ
いきます
[音楽]
4もう
まだが山も外貨をご覧のこれ
[拍手]
moon
星ではねはいみてください
ああ
いいいいいいいいいいいい
me
今までやるこの出るないでしょ
ないでしょ艦これ
[音楽]
2 tar
ああああああいいいい
何か出るを出ちゃったが思うけれど下田西べちゃっとしましたん
nan じぇい
入ったかなん
ok そうですよすー
ええええええ
すべきたぞ無事へおこしました
[音楽]
これもよろしくいい
hair magic 良いんじゃなければまあ
どうぞサード密封されています私たいあのん
おいているざーわー
[拍手]
はいというわけで無事何とかサルベージすることができましたこれ本当に効果があるの
かと思ってちょっともうちょっと色んな人にちょっと試してみようと思います
par
ああああああ
はん
par rar
[音楽]
wh yeah
ano 俺はきつい
ラメってこんなツールツリー
さあ超えてみよの経験底れます
r 4
[音楽]
[拍手]
すごいそガチャ
rar
ああああああああ yeah
これすごい所えっ
[音楽]
えいえいおー
ああああああああ
dare
これ
ブーフあっはい
を終えている
[音楽]
名前 no
じゃあ
あっはいというわけで一応強い全員とで買いで入ってしまったので思うですこれはう
危険すぎるんでとアンダー使わないと思うんですけどもまた使う着替えたら使おうと
思いますバイ
me
me あった